wir wollen aber mal so ein bisschen den
blick wenden von dem was gestern gesagt
worden ist getan worden ist wie die
zahlen gestern waren zu den konsequenzen
heute und grüße deswegen sehr hat sich
erhard scherfer
der sich kümmert um die spd schönen
guten morgen und der lars klingbeil im
interview hat
so ist als vielen dank michael krons ja
gestern ist hier noch gefeiert worden
relativ lange erst ein wenig im atrium
dann vor dem atrium in der durchfahrt
hier im willy brandt haus und auf der
straße und dann hat man sich nochmal
wenig in die dritte etage zurückgezogen
und hat auch da noch ein klein wenig
gefeiert ich unterstelle mal dass für
alle beteiligten bei dieser
bundestagswahl die nächte relativ kurz
gewesen sind aber wir können es auch
direkt nachfragen nämlich an lars
klingbeil aber ich will erstmal die
einfachste frage des tages stellen dann
haben wir den nächsten bundeskanzler
olaf scholz hat gestern ganz klar gesagt
die nächste weihnachtsansprache möchte
er halten neujahrsansprache möchte
erhalten und das war doch erfüllen er
möchte schafft das auch ich gehe davon
aus die dame während olaf scholz hat vor
ein paar wochen gesagt er will
bundeskanzler werden da ist ja belächelt
worden hat gesagt wir wollen auf platz
eins das eher belächelt worden also das
haben wir geschafft mit platz eins und
deswegen gehe ich davon aus dass andere
firmen aber bundeskanzler ist er
trotzdem noch nicht weil es ja noch
einen kandidaten gibt er zwar dramatisch
verloren hat gestern oder sagen wir
zumindest deutlich und trotzdem den
anspruch erhebt bundeskanzler werden zu
wollen wie finden sie denn dieses
manöver also das ist schon erstaunlich
dass armin laschet bei diesem historisch
schlechten wahlergebnis wo er ja auch
als kandidat abgestraft wurde dass er
einen anspruch auf das kanzleramt erhebt
die union hat sich radikal verändert in
der zeit nach angela merkel man guckt
auf die masken deals man sieht dass die
tür für jemanden wie hans-georg maßen
auf gestoßen wurde die union hat einen
völlig inhaltsleeren wahlkampf geführt
hat nur mit schmutz geworfen die ganze
zeit und da bin ich wirklich gespannt ob
fdp und grüne mit einer partei die so
deutlich verloren hat wenn man mit den
ernsthafte gespräche führen wird wie
wird das denn überhaupt ablaufen in den
nächsten tagen gibt es aus spd position
heraus schon eine strategie gibt es
überlegungen wer wann mit wem redet
jetzt nein wir werden es heute in den
gremien wir im präsidium parteivorstand
da werden wir das beraten
da ist der spiegel hat gestern die wahl
gewonnen das ist doch ein deutlicher
vorsprung der union haben und wir sehen
ja auch noch mal den persönlichen werten
das ist die menschen wollen dass olaf
scholz kanzler wird er ist derjenige dem
sie vertrauen wo sagen er soll das land
führen und deswegen werden wir jetzt
sehr zügig dann zu gesprächen einladen
aber in welcher reihenfolge wann das
sein wird das werden wir heute in den
gremien besprechen anderthalb prozent
sind jetzt nicht so ein gigantisch
großer vorsprung finde ich habe herr
schäfer wenn man guckt wo wir herkommen
noch mal vor ein paar wochen standen wir
abgeschlagen auf platz 3 13 14 prozent
sodann hat die spd angefangen zu kämpfen
olaf scholz hat überzeugt und wenn sich
die balken gestern angucken dann sieht
man ja auch es gibt einen der ganz weit
runter und es gibt drei balken die gehen
hoch und ich finde dass es schon in
ordnung wenn die drei parteien denn
jetzt erstmals vernünftige gespräche
miteinander führen jetzt ist im raum
gestern geäußert in der großen runde vom
fdp-vorsitzenden lindner dass man
möglicherweise zunächst mal mit den
grünen sprechen will also die beiden die
entscheidend sein werden für die
künftige dreier konstellation die es ja
geben muss dass sie sich erst mal
unterhalten was halten sie denn davon
also die spd hat gestern den
regierungsauftrag bekommen wir sind
stärkste kraft geworden wir sind die
stärkste fraktion im parlament
olaf scholz hat die größten kompetenz
zuschreibung hat die größten
beliebtheitswerte und daraus leiten wir
ab dass wir jetzt zu gesprächen einladen
werden und die werden jetzt führen die
das können wir machen nichts desto trotz
ist ja auch möglich dass tatsächlich fdp
und grüne er ist man sich zusammensetzen
und da schon mal gemeinsam die lage
sondieren das ist ja ein verfahren das
nicht das kann ich ja nicht verbieten
das kann ich nicht verhindern aber
nochmal ich gehe davon aus dass auch fdp
und grüne sehen dass es gestern ein
sieger gibt dass es ein wähler wunsch
gibt auch wer eine künftige regierung
anführen soll und dass man diesen wunsch
der wählerinnen und wähler dass man die
noch respektiert aber die frage ist ja
was wir finden sie dieses verfahren das
wenn das tatsächlich so kommt was nicht
ganz unwahrscheinlich ist fdp und grüne
tatsächlich erstmal gucken und ausloten
mit wem sie möglicherweise mehr
durchsetzen können ich hab nicht zu
beurteilen welche partei gerade
gespräche führt normal ich kann nur
sagen es gibt einen auftrag der
wählerinnen und wähler denen die uns
gestern ein parteien mitgegeben haben
und das klare votum lautet doch armin
laschet will man nicht im kanzleramt
olaf scholz will man im kanzleramt
und ich bin gespannt auch mit welcher
begründung dann fdp und grüne
beispielsweise in gesprächen mit der
union eintreten ein rot grün rotes
bündnis ist rechnerisch ausgeschlossen
das heißt dass fehlt so ein bisschen
auch das druckmittel in
anführungszeichen
für zukünftige verhandlungen die frage
ist ja wo sind bei der spd die so
genannten roten linien beziehungsweise
die punkte die unumkehrbar sind mit
denen sie in eine koalition gehen werden
oder scholz hat sehr deutlich gemacht
für ihn ist ein ganz wichtiges thema die
frage 12 euro mindestlohn das sollen wir
durchsetzen und wichtiges thema ist auch
kommen wir im bereich des wohnungsbaus
voran also wir haben große probleme in
gerade in vielen großen städten aber
auch im ländlichen raum was bezahlbares
wohnen angeht das sind zwei themen die
für uns sehr sehr wichtig sind als spd
wo wir auch sehen dass viele menschen
wegen dieser beiden themen uns das
vertrauen gegeben haben und insgesamt
muss man sagen hat die künftige
regierung große aufgaben die vor uns
liegen also es geht dir am umbruch der
geraden nach 16 jahren merkel da es geht
um die frage staatsmodernisierung es
geht um digitalisierung es geht um den
ganz wichtigen bereich des klimaschutzes
wo in den nächsten vier jahren
substantiell wir was schaffen müssen das
sind große aufgaben und ich glaube wenn
jetzt gespräche stattfinden zwischen
parteien muss man sich erst mal darauf
einigen ob alle diese großen ziele sehen
ob alles sagen da muss jetzt wirklich
etwas passieren also es brauche eine
regierung die anpackt bei den großen
themen jetzt habe ich die finanzierung
dieser schönen pläne um ist denn auch
das war thema im wahlkampf bei der spd
beispielsweise vermögenssteuer war ein
thema aber auch die erhöhung der
spitzensteuersätze die haben sie jetzt
nicht erwähnt sind das jetzt nicht mehr
ohne umsturz ware positionen erst mal
haben wir sogar gesagt wir wollen für 95
prozent der menschen steuern senken und
die sind nicht wir wollen gucken dass
menschen entlastet werden ich glaube
auch da stellt man schnell eine
einigkeit her und was aber der
wichtigste punkt war in der ganzen frage
finanzierung ist dass wir immer gesagt
haben wir brauchen zukunftsinvestitionen
50 milliarden zukunftsinvestitionen die
am ende sein müssen und wir haben
programm vorgelegt das durchgerechnet
ist mit denen gehen wir jetzt auch in
die verhandlung rein und werden damit
den anderen sprechen und werden wir über
die fdp beispielsweise sprechen
dann verstehe ich überhaupt nicht wie
man den schwerpunkt setzen kann bei
einer abschaffung des
solidaritätsbeitrags
solidaritätszuschlag für zehn milliarden
sind das die die topverdiener entlastet
werden aber dieses geld würde ich lieber
in zukunftsinvestitionen im bereich
klimaschutz im bereich digitalisierung
im bereich staatsmodernisierung stecken
aber das sind konkrete gespräche die man
jetzt untereinander mit den parteien
führen wird erhöhung spitzensteuersatz
muss also nicht zwingend sein verstehe
ich das jetzt richtig wir wollen das als
spd wir sagen das ist auch sagen die
möglichkeit um dann 95 prozent der
menschen zu entlasten
die grünen sagen dass auch und jetzt
gucken wir mal wie die gespräche konkret
laufen die spd hat sich ausgezeichnet in
den vergangenen mehr als zwölf monaten
durch das was man gemeinhin
geschlossenheit nennt es hat keine
öffentlichen diskussionen gegeben über
den kurs hat keine öffentlichen
diskussionen gegeben über das personal
weder bezüglich des kanzlerkandidaten
als auch der beiden vorsitzenden wie
lange geht das gut oder wie lange hält
das an wenn es jetzt ans eingemachte
geht wenn jetzt für eine regierung unter
bundes unter einem bundeskanzler scholz
auch positionen möglicherweise geräumt
werden müssen aus dem bekannten
kompromiss gründen will wie es ja eben
auch schon angesprochen haben als
kollegin bestehen immer aus kompromissen
aber trotzdem haben wir deutlich gemacht
was wir wollen zwölf euro mindestlohn
ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt und die
geschlossenheit die man erlebt hat in
der spd die ist ja echt der haben wir
hart gearbeitet das war nicht immer so
in der spd in der tat aber jetzt die
letzten zwölf monate hat man das gemerkt
das ist an vielen stellen hat sich das
bewährt ist auf die probe gestellt
worden die haben es immer wieder auch
geschafft diese geschlossenheit zu
halten und das werden alle auch die
nächsten monate erleben dass es so
weitergeht da gucken wir natürlich
darauf lassen geben sie uns abschließend
einen kurzen einblick in ihre arbeits
und seelenleben der vergangenen sagen
wir mal ruhig fünf sechs monate wie war
das für sie
spannend anstrengend und ich bin jetzt
auch ein bisschen froh dass es gestern
dann vorbei ist denn dankbar für das was
ich erleben durfte ich meine noch mal
wir haben aufgeholt ich war im ganzen
land unterwegs ich habe erlebt wie die
partei motiviert ist viele leute zu uns
zurückgekommen sind die wir in den
letzten jahren noch verloren haben
standen wieder menschen an info ständen
die uns 2005 2009 nicht mehr gewählt
haben und das ist ein ganz großes
privileg dass menschen uns vertrauen
wieder geschenkt haben es hat wahnsinnig
viel spaß gemacht für die spd unterwegs
zu seinen letzten wochen werden eine
kurze pause jetzt lieber oder kommt
jetzt die zweite luft im hinblick auf
mögliche koalitionsgespräche also ein
zwei abende die ich mal zu hause meine
frau verbringen könnte wären schon ganz
nah es klingt mit einem auch
persönlichen einblick in die vergangenen
monate und vielleicht in die kommenden
monate es kann sich ja durchaus ziehen
das war erstmal von uns wir melden uns
beim nächsten passender gelegenheit
wieder erst mal zurück zu michael krons